what do you got for us buddy
yeah hi uh so thank you for your content
all that blah blah blah i have to go
into work real fast i'll be fast about
this okay so given the fact that you're
saying that relationship should probably
be temporary or on average they're going
to be temporary how allowed should you
even
allow how attached to a woman should you
allow yourself to become in your opinion
okay well there's a few different things
there so i didn't say that i think you
know relationships should be temporary
it's just an observation that they
generally are temporary
right so you know it's why you hear a
lot of these guys say that you know
she's not yours it's just your turn sort
of thing
so
haven't haven't taken that into
consideration human beings are not
lifelong monogamous pair bonders we're
just not
um even even in you know historical
parts where
100 years ago there was no social media
and it was socially enforced to be you
know like husband and wife till death do
his part they still went outside of the
marriage right like you know men richie
women would be you know would betray and
you know all those things still existed
back then there was just no things like
instagram and social media to amplify it
or dating apps make it easier
so there's that part of it so
you're the last part of your question is
how should you handle that
yeah like just given the fact that the
majority of relationships are going to
be temporary
how attached
as a man do you think you should allow
yourself to become no woman because
obviously you can't be completely
disattached from her but you also can't
become like a symp that's like what has
one item is yeah got it got it and you
know for the most part younger guys
don't have the fortitude to
deal with that
yep it's it's mostly younger guys that
really struggle with that and it's like
you know they have the one itis they
have the soulmate myth they you know
they see a hot girl and you know she
touches his pee pee and she's a unicorn
sort of thing and you know he wants to
marry her and date her and you know make
her his girlfriend within like the first
two dates sort of stuff
um
you just have to you just have to
understand you know relationships for
what they are which is a lot of the
stuff that i talk about in my book i
don't know if you've read my book yeah i
have yeah so review yeah like one of the
part thank you um one of the parts that
i talk about in there is like you know
when a woman says something to you like
i love you zach then you have to then
you have to in your head add what to it
for now
right now
right so whenever a woman says it she'll
that she has a feeling right now
then you add to it in your head right
now
because a woman always reserves
reserves the right to change your body
at any given time so when you
understand female nature
it'll help you i'm not saying it's going
to solve the one-itis i'm not saying
that you're never going to like have
your heart broken or be
or have an unhealthy attachment to a
chick in the future it's probably gonna
happen even if you are red pilled and
you understand you've unplugged from all
the [ __ ] not sort of stuff it's
probably gonna happen at some point i
mean you know you catch the feelings for
you know you catch the fee fees
and you know she does all the cool stuff
that you like i mean you know it works
out for a while and then it doesn't work
out for for a while then you're left
hanging and women have always had an
easier time at moving from guy to guy
they're expert mate switchers there's
there's studies i don't i don't have it
here on the court of my desk anymore but
there's studies that research facilities
have done where you know women are are
very very
adapt to mate switching you know the
whole warbride notion that i that i also
talked about in the book too right you
know where brides have been studied for
a long time
um it's a common phenomenon but men men
don't have that capability we're not
evolved to
deal with that as well as women are so
long and short of it is it's gonna
happen you're gonna have to suck it up
okay
all right i mean i can try to unplug the
hell out of you and red pill you until
the you know sun goes down and comes up
tomorrow but at the end of it all you
know if you don't
you know if you haven't gone through the
reps if you haven't gone through the
chaos if you haven't dealt with it if if
you haven't seen you know female nature
for what it truly is once twice three
times
you know then you're gonna have a hard
time dealing with it right so
it's just a matter of time how old are
you right now
21. all right i'll let you get back to
work but i'll keep talking i mean like
you can watch the rest of it but it's
it's just one of those things that you
have to
adjust to
okay all right thank you for your time
yeah it's
like there's no
there's no quick and easy you know
solution guys it's just like
you know women are gonna betray you it's
you know it's a fact of life you know
it's it's just gonna happen you're going
to be shocked to realize that she's not
sugar and spice and all things nice and
just because you say i love you that
she's always going to love you and that
she's always going to be loyal to you
so you will be betrayed and that's just
part of being a man
some guys it happens to more often than
other guys
you know other guys
you know for the you know for the rare
ones it doesn't happen to that much at
all so
it is what it is i mean
understanding female nature is one thing
but
understanding it and kind of setting
aside feelings is um a different thing
altogether but when it happens to you a
few times and you understand it and you
get used to it you move through it a lot
faster and it's less of a problem for
you so if that makes sense
let me get the super here corey or kerry
says
have eastern eu fiance eastern europe so
i'm guessing like slovakia
like you know that part maybe ukrainian
or something like that amazing people
but when around other high
value couples or men in public i notice
fiance seems to vibe differently she
postures a bit more and doesn't seem
present she seems more in her head
insight
that my friend is hypergamy uh you put a
like
eastern european women are beautiful um
they are
they are women on hard mode if i'm being
honest i had a thing in my 20s for
eastern european women um
and uh
i mean how can i put it
um
beautiful
fun but
they are hypergamy turbocharged i'll put
it that way um if you're not on your
game if you're not competent they have
very little wiggle room for mistakes
they don't have a lot of tolerance for
[ __ ] um very very hardcore people i
think it's probably from like
um decades of socialism and communism um
i remember there was a guy that was once
telling me that they're a very sad
people it was what he said something
along that lines
um and not to say that they're like
unhappy or sad but it's just like
if if something
better
comes up or looks good you know in
contrast
then
they're always kind of like weighing out
that option right
um so that's probably what's happening
in your situation carrie hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you